[Music]
and I was confronted with this question
what materials to use for this class and
I was thinking to myself you know I know
a lot of my own games by heart but I
don't know a lot of the world champions
and those games but I remember them and
they make a fantastic impression on me
in this game in white
Edward Lasker known as unfortunately the
lower Lasker or the lesser Lasker
because of his namesake Emanuel Lasker
Edward Lasker german-american very long
lived he lived in there was 90 in New
York City nonetheless made important
contributions to the game and he will be
inducted during the US Championships in
26 2017 at the opening ceremony into the
u.s. chess Hall of Fame a recognition
what well overdue by the way the amazing
thing about this game is that it wasn't
even played in a tournament he had just
gotten to London and he just sat down
with his opponent George Thomas and they
were playing a skittle game and it was
loud 'add around the world as a great
king hunt and we all loved King Hunt
forcing the opponent up the board and
this was a great demonstration of that
and as a young boy when I saw this game
for the first time it made a really
powerful impression for me the problem
is I had memorized the game at the time
and then in my blitz games whenever I
tried to get the same combination never
work my opponents knew the game as well
well let's see the first of three games
that we're going to show you today of
games you should learn
or know by heart okay
why just develop the thesis very quickly
and immediately takes action in the
center black develops Bishop d3 Bishop
g7 and then suddenly and out of the blue
comes this very powerful move queen h5
and this is where your spidey sense
should really be on tilt whenever I got
this position with white my opponents
instantly captured this knight on e5 and
I I could never play the combination
that was played in the game in the game
George Thomas by Queen e7 BAM Queen
takes h7 check to the King no choice you
have to take the Queen and take with a
double check the very fearsome double
check of the knight and the bishop the
king could not go backwards step back
because there's a very beautiful double
night checkmate after Knight g6 instead
the King had to come up the board
it was dragged up the board and this is
the King Hunt they're all very excited
of case or like how to do it how to pull
the king up the board
well this Knight is suggestive because
the knight on f6 does a good job at
protecting the square on h5 black have
no choice if King must come up the board
h4 check no choice g3 check no choice
Bishop e2 check now should check here
and here Lasker failed he played the
most King d2 check and mate how do you
played the move castles
it would have been a unique example of
castling with checkmate
but as Edward himself explained his
decision he explained that he was an
engineer and inventor by trade and
castling involved using two pieces and
for efficiency we used one so that was
the first game of games you should know
by heart this was the anytime you see
this example you just kind of like get
cheered and warmed up
I'll suite it it okay let's go to our
next game No and our next game oh you
have the audience oh yeah oh yeah this
is a very sweet game it was played in a
very celebrated event in Belgrade it was
called the USSR versus the rest of the
world and bent Larsen played board one
for the rest of the world and again keep
in mind the day 1970 and two years later
Bobby Fischer would become world
champion so a lot of Americans they're
thinking to themselves wow the rest of
the world team a selection they put that
in Larsen ahead of Bobby Fischer no
Bobby Fischer put them Larsen ahead of
Bobby Fischer it was actually Bobby
Fischer who agreed that bent Larsen
should play board 1 and here been played
against Boris Spassky and that was known
for his little offbeat openings and he
loved to play the early Queens
fianchetto and I don't know if his
actually called Larsen's opening but it
should be because he introduced a lot of
great ideas with this movie 3 Boris on
the other hand he took the
the proper classical approach if his
opponent is not going to occupy the
center then he would be fine it should
be 296 C 4 and we have a kind of English
not exactly in English but this move
Knight f3 is extremely provocative the
move Knight f3 attacks upon on e5 and
basically encourages the pawn on e5 to
move forward a more restrained approach
by white might have been to play the
move g3 event had any inkling of what
was about to happen he would have chosen
g3 instead he's going to go down and be
history books as a victim of a great
combination 95 attacking upon Boris
didn't ask wasn't ready to be asked
twice he played classical development
Bishop c5 Knight takes pawn takes a to
e3 and at this moment I you might think
okay every games kind of even until you
start to look deeper in the position and
realize that this pawn on e4 is really a
kind of a wedge it really interferes
with White's ideas of playing D to d4
and it's restraining this Bishop on f1
so in some ways and it's kind of
mysterious the way it happened
black is actually four choice Bishop f5
Queen c2 Queen c7 Bishop e2 castles
again a very nice development by black
black connexes rook the opening is over
for him white lags and development he
has not yet castled and his pieces are
cramped and again that space the
cramping in the space is all due to this
pawn on e4 if there was no AM Pathan
rule on Pathan move D to D for what
actually be brilliant here and it's
lucky that the French 500 years ago
introduced the idea of on the Sun
otherwise after d4 we kind of be happy
to have light but before would be met by
E for takes d3 capturing upon and that
would be that F for bad move this move a
typical bent he's trying to gain space
on the kingside the pond on Eve on f4
controls two very nice squares and he's
taking advantage of the fact that on the
song is not a good idea because the
Queen takes with check and black doesn't
have time to capture the bishop in
return so f4 however it neglects his own
development his pieces are still on the
first rank and Bora says okay this is
really too much and plays the move
Knight g4 so the idea of spassky's is
very simple you want to go check and
after g2 g3 he just wants to infiltrate
in the whites camp also with this move
Knight g4 he Spassky is looking at
opportunities of sacrificing pieces
against the e3 pawn especially as
White's King is still in the center then
says okay I'm not afraid of any
immediate sacrifice on e3 I'll play the
move g3 with the intention of playing h2
h3 and intention a move that he couldn't
play at once because h3 would have
allowed Queen h4 check winning for black
so g2 g3 prepares h3 and now Spassky
realizes that the move h2 h3 is coming
the night will be driven
back and then white will play Knight c3
castles and white will be okay so
Spassky thinks to himself well how can I
take advantage of my opponents lack of
development h5 pow then says well what's
that I'm going to kick your knight back
and Laura says a Russian never retreats
I'm going ahead H for blasting open on
the kingside then says I'll take that
I'm a I'm a piece ahead and then after
capturing after the captures on g3
realizes of course his rook is under
threat he doesn't want to trade rooks
and allow blacks rook to recapture then
plays rook g1 so white is a piece up
give him two moves Knight c3 Castle
black resigns it's over Queen h4 that's
another piece check and the King is
going to run Spassky however comes up
with a phenomenal move when I saw this
as a kid it just again it made this kind
of electrical shock impression on me I
didn't give up my pieces I didn't like
losing my pieces ever even on it on a
heads-up trade although that sub trades
were okay but this move Wow
BAM all for a tempo White has to capture
the rook and now g2 now we can see that
if the rook has to maintain control of
the promotional square g1 but when the
moves to g1 the oh sorry the Queen
would come over check and queen h1 and
black would win back all of the
sacrifice material as well as the fact
that White's King is under attack as
well as the fact that white is
undeveloped so that was why then played
rook f1 check anyway takes and white
resigned the final move might have been
you should check and mate so this was
quite a wipeout in the game
I believe bent ended up and the four
games played with one and a half half
one and a half
nope army to one with Spassky but then
he beat spassky's replacement and he
finished to two on board won a very
credible result Bobby one on board two
against Tigran Petrosian that this was a
very nice game and again one that really
made a very powerful impression upon me
when I was young the third game that I
chose for tonight where he came head
still mystifies those who watched it in
real time who were witnesses to the game
as well as the generations who have
played over the game thereafter I
it's like jim mash jeans mash I'm not
really too sure it was a fellow he was a
writer for Sports Illustrated and his
editors had given an assignment to go
and find Bobby Fischer this was just
before the scheduled 1975 match between
Bobby Fischer champion and Challenger
and atole Karpov and everybody was
saying will
he played this match in 1975 so Jim
decided that he didn't want to go and
meet Fisher and you know get buzzed off
like you know you don't know nothing
about nothing I'm not talking to you
kind of thing and he really wanted to
get into Fisher's history his past his
thoughts and he decided that even though
he didn't play chess he would memorize
this game and that would convince Bobby
Fischer that he was somebody worth
talking so he memorized the game even
though he didn't even understand all the
rules and he came to actually love the
game as a result of learning this and
then he it inspired him to learn the
rules the game was played if Robert
Byrne there yes yes and he read he read
all of the all of the report yeah and
Robert Byrne is explaining this game to
me and I thought it was a very funny
explanation was that he was afraid he
was afraid of Bobby Fischer so he wanted
to keep the game as controlled as
possible and not give Bobby any
opportunities whatsoever of winning or
upsetting the balance and Robert felt
that Bobby was the type of player that
white/black bring pieces read pieces he
was going to play for a win so Roberts
attitude was I don't have to create the
energy my opponent's going to come after
me and you know I'll draw a line a line
in the sand he'll cross the line and
I'll spank him so it went just as
planned this game went just perfectly as
planned as Robert had everything under
control what we have
the kind of a hybrid groom fell Kings
Indian defense and the position has been
played many many many games I'm not
going to say thousands but you get the
idea by players with the white pieces
who are trying to make a draw and he
plays III and if you look at the
position after all of these moves have
been played you see a fantastic symmetry
the pawn formations for both sides
you've got six parney you've got Kevin
the center King side to it hold up I'll
do it again
you've got five on the center as well as
the King side five each for both players
two versus two on the King side and the
only open file is the rook as the C file
both guys will put their rooks on the C
file there'll be a big chopping and
white bishop on g2 is actually has a
better view than this bishop on g7 so
Robert felt that if anybody had the
advantage it was him and he just knew
that Bobby was going to play this move
e5 which he was going to refute because
as we can all see business isolated
Queens pawn and as soon as black white
builds up the pressure on this pawn
Roberts going to win so if you look at
the position from White's perspective
white is really a happy camper is king
is safe as can be so Robert says let me
win the pot this is the famous wrong
rook
so the rook on s1 is actually doing some
nice defensive work for White's King in
particular holding down this
f2 of course Robert played the move
would be 1 because this Bishop that's an
annoying Bishop it's attacking this
Knight which is pin to this rook on f1
so Robert thinking I'm about to move my
pin night I'm going to capture this pawn
as it turns out he should have used the
other rook wrong rook if he had played
this rook move in his 60 memorable games
Bobby gives a very very very long
sequence of moves and explains why the
game would have been a draw okay so
rugby one wrong move Knight b3 and
that's really in pertinent you know I
mean the night I mean you know like how
dare you you know I'm well developed you
just put your knight on d3 it the knight
on d3 does a really good job of
protecting this pawn on d5 is blocks up
the clogs up the D file Queen c2 very
simple idea
Knights got a move if you don't move
that night I'm about to play whipped
eggs d3 and we can find score sheets the
game's over
rook yeah Robert had analyzed the four
sequence Knight takes F to King takes F
to Knight check King back Knight takes
Queen B to Knight takes a one-night
takes D 1 rook takes D 1 and he felt
that the two pieces for the rook that
this was going to be a position in his
favor that is to say that he's about to
play the move Bishop takes d5 the night
will come nicely to f4 and blacks King
will come under pressure okay
they were grandmasters this would play
that the u.s. championship
were grandmasters who had been analyzing
in front of a live audience who had
dismissed this sacrifice by Bobby for
the identical reasons that Robert Byrne
had and they they were saying that Bobby
Stan's worse and then Bobby played the
most incredible move ever like Knight
takes G to write didn't anybody teach
Bobby Fischer that the look is more
valuable than the night and he just
instead of taking the rook he takes a
bishop the Bobby had seen an
unbelievable he had an unbelievable
imagination for to to even contemplate
this moves because what he had seen is
that once you eliminate this Bishop on G
to this LightSquared Bishop is this
great defender of the King and when you
just you don't have to analyze moves you
kind of just sit back and you look and
you go hey man you know whites King it's
pretty bare there's a lot of light
square weaknesses around whites King now
and whites king is the target but now
all the grandmasters who were doing the
commentary who were berating Bobby's
idea in the first place
secondly to give up the bishop give up
the night for the bishop we're saying
that Bobby is no longer worse he simply
lost Bobby play d4 sacrificing the pawn
the bishop came back to b7 with a check
King jump to f1 Queen to d7 and here we
have this very ugly check looming let's
see what happened next
yes so Bobby so so Bobby plays the move
Queen d7 and the exciting news buzzes
around the tournament
the game's over games over so everybody
so the grand masters who are explaining
to the live audience saying okay the
game is over
Bobby has lost to Robert Byrne were shot
when Robert Byrne comes in and go
congratulations robbery said why I lost
so everybody had egg on their face so
let's see why Robert Byrne resigned
had he played the move Queen f2 so what
sorry
so what black threat is is that if white
allow the black status coat-check King
Bishop take d4 check clean mate on g2
thanks to those LightSquared bishop so
the move Queen H Queen f2 pardoning is
designed that after check King here
the knight is now protected by the rook
but rook e1 check whoa what a move we
cannot capture the rook with our Queen
because we have to guard the G to square
we have to take the rook instead with
our rook and now Bishop takes d4 and we
can't take the bishop because once again
to mate and if we don't do anything the
queen is coming
the threat is Queen G to checkmate we
play rook e3 you take and it smells like
a bad dream as it is recurring mate that
takes place on g2 we want to go back a
moment to this moment when Byrne shows
the square F one why didn't he choose
the square G one
this is a classic combination that has
occurred
unfortunately I've been victimized by it
but I've also been on the other side if
we notice the knight on d4 has two
defenders the Queen on b2 and the rook
on d1 the Queen on d2 has one defender
if we the rook on undie one if we could
be Cody coy that defender away after
Bishop takes check Queen takes if that
rook was not on d1 black would win
brilliantly by Queen takes Queen check
how can we decoy the Queen check you
cannot take the rook because your queen
is left unprotected the king would have
to move and now Queen takes rook takes
rook takes and at the end of this
sequence of moves white would be an
exchange now which explains Elsa's
understand that after the check King f1
Robert was trying to protect the square
e 1 and the the ironic thing was that
when he played the move King f1 he was
trying to protect the square e 1 and in
the sequence that we just seen queen h3
check King G 1 how cruel this is the e 1
square is again the undoing of Robert
Byrne this was considered one of Bobby's
greatest games and not only because of
the combination what he was trying to do
is also because Robert Byrne was one of
the best grandmasters in the world he
became a candidate Grandmaster and
always a top player in a US Championship
and here he was this top Grandmaster
with the white pieces and Bobby went
through
like a hot knife through soft butter
because Bobby wasn't taking a draw so
that was a game that really games that
you should know by heart but games that
you should be familiar with so these are
the first three and I'll be choosing a
lot more for the lectures ahead as well
the other GM and res I hope you liked
this show's contribution
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]